fusion GPS founder Glenn Simpson gave
secret testimony to Congress a while ago
it was released this week by Dianne
Feinstein the transcript seems to have
unwelcome and probably unintended
revelations for Democrats though for
instance Simpsons testimony suggests
that even as Fusion was encouraging an
FBI investigation of Trump and his
campaign it was also trying to hinder an
investigation into the Clinton
Foundation huh Peter Schweitzer is very
familiar with subjects like these in
real Clinton cash he's an expert on all
the arms of the vast Clinton nonprofit
and profitable octopus he joins us
tonight so Peter tell us what this
transcript suggests well what it
suggests is that Glenn Simpson did not
like the fact that the FBI in August and
then later October was looking to reopen
the Clinton email investigation and in
fact he testified that when he heard
that the FBI was considering this that
he contacted the FBI he encouraged other
journalists to contact the FBI and his
partner Christopher Steele the ex
British intelligence officer stopped
cooperating with the FBI on the Trump
dossier this is all according to Glenn
Simpson himself so it raises questions
you know about who this guy actually is
he's not the sort of disinterested
fact-finder who was sort of shocked and
appalled by what they found
regarding Trump that he was actually
doing the bidding of his client which is
we now know happened to be the Hillary
Clinton campaign but the Brooke but the
broader bidding not just I mean so my
understanding was here's a former
newspaper reporter hired to dig up
information on her opponent that's
pretty conventional that happens a lot
during campaign right but this suggests
that he was in fact a partisan trying to
help the Clintons in another arena
entirely yeah that's exactly right and
look I mean you know he continues to use
the term Simpson that this is sort of
opposition research
you know Tucker you and I have been
around the block in Washington for a
while that dossier was not opposition
research opposition research is only
useful if you can gather information and
then give it to the media
the media can replicate it the Trump
dossier was all anonymous sources you
know based on on two to three iterations
it was shared with newspaper reporters
but more specifically was shared with
the FBI and the whole process shows how
terrible the sausage-making was in this
case I mean fusion GPS is is trying to
intervene in a possible Clinton
Foundation investigation
I'm sorry Clinton email investigation
they're pushing this product that that
you know Simpson admits in his testimony
he never verified he never attempted to
verified it just really shows that what
his job was was to try to wreak havoc on
the Trump campaign and help Hillary
Clinton by initiating a federal criminal
investigation into the Trump campaign
not by digging up useable op oh yeah
that's exactly right and so what they
did is in a couple of stages they shared
this dossier around with media outlets
then they took it to the FBI and of
course keep in mind that we know of at
least one senior Department of Justice
official whose spouse was working for
fusion GPS but once they share it with
the FBI that then leaked further that
the FBI is looking at the dossier so in
effect it's it's a twofer from that
stamp shouldn't use the FBI as a
component of your campaign I think we
can all agree
Peter Schweitzer thank you for that that
was really interesting and really dark
so I grateful that you explained that